АИ ачипқәа рџьармыкьа
Даҽа ҽеиқәак цәырҵит.
Ахшыбаҩ асистемақәа
АИПО аламҭалазы
Аҩбатәи аџьармыкьа уажәнатә еилагоит.
АИПО ахәқәа рыбжьара еишьҭаргыланы еизҳауеит.
20-ынтә еиҳаны аҽаҩра ҟаҵоуп
Апотенциалтә ахә ашьара ҳазҭоу аамҭазы 50 миллиард доллар иазааигәоуп.
АИ чиптә компаниақәа зегьы еицлабуеит
Изылшода ачип еиҵазтәуа?
GPUs еиҳа иӷәӷәаны ианыҟало
Ари акомпаниа иагеит...
Зынӡа еиԥшым амҩақәа
Иҟанаҵо ачипсқәа
Ахаҿы аҵкыс еиҳауп
Ишиашоу авафель зегьы
Ачип еиԥш ахархәара
Ахшыбаҩ хада аалыҵ, WSE
Уи аҭоурых аҿы иреиҳау чипуп
Аҵыхәтәантәи аверсиа аинтеграциа амоуп
4 триллион транзисторқәа
900,000 АИ агәыцәқәа
Ари амодель маҷк иадамзаргьы иаԥыхра алшоит
Ачипқәа рыбжьара адыррақәа реимадара аҵәахра
Уажәазы ​​уи ахшыҩҵак аццакыра
28 хынтә еиҳа иццакуеит Нвидиа В200 аасҭа
Уи адагьы, ақәԥаразы иҟоу алшарақәа иреиуоуп ҳәа иԥхьаӡоуп
Нвидиа аҳасабратә мчхаратә система аҵаҟа иҟоу акомпаниақәа иреиуоуп
Ааигәа Cerebras еиуеиԥшым аҿахҵәарақәа аиуит.
Мета раԥхьаӡа акәны уи ачип ахархәеит.
Аусура Лама 4 амодел ахҳәаа
Ҳазҭоу ашықәс алагамҭазы
OpenAI даҽа шықәсырацәалатәи аҳасабратә мчхара аиуразы Аиқәшаҳаҭра анапаҵыҩра мҩаԥнагеит
Аконтрактқәа зегьы рыхә 20 миллиард доллар инаӡеит.
AWS анаҩс ирыланарҵәеит
Уи ачипқәа аԥсҭҳәатә платформа ралагалара
Ахшыбаҩ ахашәалахәы
Хышықәса рыла 20 хынтә еизҳаит
"Альтернативтә АИ чип алагара" аҟынтә
Хәыҷы-хәыҷла иҭаланы
Адунеизегьтәи АИ аинфраструктуратә система
Ахшыбаҩқәа рымҩа
Иахьа уи даара ахаҿы иаагоуп.
Аха зны Силиконтәи ахәҭаҿы зегь реиҳа ихшыҩдоу акы акәны иԥхьаӡан.
Зыҟалашьа змам апроектқәа иреиуоуп
Уи АИ ачип ацикл аҿы иҟоуп
Уи "аԥсҭазаара-аԥсра" х-етапкк ирхысит.
Вафель зегьы амҩа
иаанагоит
Еиҳау аарыхратә уадаҩра
Еиҵоу аура
насгьы даараӡа иҳараку аарыхратә харџьқәа
Техас Инструментс, ИТТ, егьырҭ акомпаниақәа рҽазыршәеит
Аха аҵыхәтәан
Зегьы лҵшәадахеит.
Зны аусхкы аҟны иԥхьаӡан
Амиссиа ҟалашьа амам
Ахшыбаҩ ԥшьышықәса аҭаххеит.
Урҭ еиуеиԥшым аинженертә уадаҩрақәа ириааит.
Аҵыхәтәан 2019 азы
WSE актәи абиԥара ҭыҵит.
Аалыҵ аԥҵазаргьы
Аха аџьармыкьа уи иаҿагыло иалагеит.
NVIDIA CUDA аекосистема ацхыраарала
АИ адунеи аҿы инагӡаны аҳра аура алагара
АИ ачип аус арура
Акапиталтә хьаҵра аколлективтә еиԥылара
СамбаНова
Ҳабана, егьырҭ акомпаниақәа рацәаны
Мамзаргьы икаҳар
Мамзаргьы амаргинализациа
Ацеребрақәагьы зныкыр аусураҿы ауадаҩрақәа рызцәырҵит.
Еиду Арабтәи Аимлаҭқәа ртехнологиатә гәыԥ G42 аус рыцура
Уи Церебрас и "ԥсҭазааратә цәаҳәа" ҳәа иԥхьаӡан.
ChatGPT ацәырҵра ашьҭахь
Уи еиҭакра ҿыцкгьы аанагеит.
Ахшыбаҩқәа рҭыԥ аҽыԥсахра иалагеит.
Аамҭаҵәҟьаҿы ахҳәааҟаҵаратә инфраструктура
Сентиабр 2024
Церебрас раԥхьаӡа акәны IPO азы афаилқәа ҟанаҵоит.
Аха, G42 ахашәалахәы заҵәык инамаданы...
Апропорциа даара идуун, убри аҟынтә еиҭахәаԥштәын.
Аҵыхәтәан, урҭ 2025 шықәсазы рхы рықәырҵар акәхеит.
АИ аҳасабратә мчра аибашьра инагӡаны имҩаԥысуеит
Аԥынгыла ӷәӷәа зыхҟьо аҳасабратә мчра ахаҭа ауп.
Аԥсҟы аҟаҵара ахҳәаа аццаки аҭак аҵәахреи
Ажәытәан ус иԥхьаӡан
Мыцхәы агрессивтә Церебрас архитектура
Ус акәымкәа, абзиарақәа аанарԥшуа иалагеит.
Аџьармыкьа аԥшаара иалагеит
Аҩбатәи авариант Нвидиа ада
Ахшыбаҩқәа уи аҭагылазаашьа ихы иархәаны
АИ аԥсҭҳәеи асуперкомпьютертә усбарҭақәеи рахь аиасра
Еишьҭагыланы OpenAI аҳамҭақәа раиура
Аклиент дуқәа
Аамҭаказы
Церебрас ҩаԥхьа IPO азы арзаҳал ҟанаҵеит.
Аха, Церебрас аахәаҩцәа
Иахьагьы даара еизакуп
2025 азы Еиду Арабтәи Аимлаҭқәа рҿы еизыҟоу ҩыџьа аклиентцәа, G42
МБЗУАИ ицны
Урҭ зегьы еицырзеиԥшу, уажәгьы ахашәалахәы 86% рхы аладырхәуеит.
Ҳәарас иаҭахузеи, ҳаргьы иаабоит
Аҵыхәтәантәи аамҭазы Серебас даара активра аазырԥшуеит.
Америка Еидгылаҿы аклиент дуқәа рырҭбаара
Акомпаниа атехнологиатә мҩатә харҭәаа иазкны
Аалыҵқәеи акапиталтә усмҩаԥгатәқәеи
Уи ашьҭахь
Иара убасгьы иҟалоит Церебрас иазку аепизод
Еиҳа иҵаулоу авидеоанализ
Бзиала шәаабеит Силиконтәи ашьхеибаркыра 101